now India and Pakistan are facing their
worst plague of locusts in decades
authorities in both countries fear of
food security crisis and even as
Pakistan struggles with the economic
fallout of the coronavirus lockdown its
agricultural sector says the insect
infestation poses a greater challenge
these tiny insects are far from fussy
eaters feasting in swarms of millions
they're now threatening to out eat
Pakistan's population at a critical time
the locust threat is several times more
dangerous than the corona virus I would
say it is a hundred times a thousand
times more dangerous than Corona when
you were fighting against corona virus
you had crops grains vegetables things
to eat no one went to bed hungry while
Pakistan's economy is really from the
ongoing coronavirus lockdown the UN's
Food and Agriculture Organization
estimates its agricultural losses from
locusts could surpass five billion
dollars this year
authorities have set up a National
Response team to assist 61 districts of
the country that are under threat the
first and second weeks of June are going
to be critical for us because the
locusts that are now in Iran and in
Muscat will start heading towards
Pakistan to combat that we have
stationed helicopters in various desert
regions that fall along the way in the
meantime desperate farmers waiting for
help have had to take matters into their
own hands trying to drive the locusts
away with noise
in neighboring India it may sound like a
party but there's nothing to celebrate
as the country struggles with the same
problem devastated crops a further
threat to the region which is also
struggling with economic costs of lock
down here teens are scrambling to stop
the swarms before breeding can take
place during the monsoon season which
begins in July